foreign
I'm sure many of you have had an
experience like this where you pitch an
idea or concept and it turns out
someone's already done it in many
respects better a few weeks ago I made a
video where I discussed the
possibilities for an official Zelda
dungeon maker in the same vein as Mario
maker I talked about how I think it
could be done and how to handle some of
the mechanics that come into play when
constructing a dungeon-like environment
My overall conclusions came down to keep
it simple no coding no node setups
nothing too complex that would
discourage the average player after all
just like Mario Maker it's supposed to
be a video game and not a game engine
something everyone can have fun with
turns out there's already a project like
this in development right now Super
Dungeon maker a game where you create
your own dungeons upload them and play
other people's Creations there's even
future plans for a single player story
mode there were quite a few different
projects brought to my attention in the
comments section of my original Zelda
maker video many of them fan projects
like super Zelda maker and z-quest
classic or game engine specifically
designed for 2D action refugees like
Solaris and Legend maker but Super
Dungeon maker was by far the most
popular suggestion and it's easy to see
why the Solaris engine and Legend maker
are both amazing projects however they
are not video games there's no pickup
and play element to them they are PC
only development tools for aspiring game
designers as for super Zelda maker and
z-quest classic again very impressive
projects but in my video I was talking
about something official something that
would actually get published preferably
and selfishly on a platform that I own
and while realistically speaking given
Nintendo's track record there's just no
way they would ever endorse a Zelda fan
project like this let alone publish it
on their own platform regardless of
quality Super Dungeon maker on the other
hand features its own distinct art style
and character so as not to infringe on
any copyright in fact just recently it
widely surpassed its Kickstarter goals
to get the game published on Nintendo
switch so it's well on its way to join
the many Indie gems already present on
the system as such in today's video I
want to talk about the game for a bit to
show its potential compared to the ideas
I talked about in my video and what to
expect from it in the future now full
disclosure this is technically a
sponsorship after seeing my dungeon
maker video the people behind the game
reached out to me to see if I was
perhaps interested in covering their
project since well it does almost
exactly what I talked about in the video
those who are well acquainted with me
and my channel know that I normally
don't do sponsorships I tried it once
and I hated every second of it but I
decided to make an exception because I
did quite literally ask for a game like
this to be made and after spending a few
afternoons playing it I can safely say
that unlike raid Shadow Legends this is
a game I genuinely support and want to
talk about and while yes I am getting
paid a modest fee for my efforts my one
condition was that I would be given
complete freedom to voice my own
opinions and potential criticisms and
not become a Salesman for the game which
they wholeheartedly agreed with with all
that said let's take a look at Super
Dungeon maker first and foremost let me
get this out of the way first because
it's by far the most important aspect of
the game you play as a chicken right
there that's 10 out of 10 game of the
year material because chickens are the
best and if you disagree mifa here wants
to have a strong word with you while
Super Dungeon maker is definitely its
own thing it's also very self-aware
about its Inspirations I mean Our Hero's
name is fink whose ancestors migrated
from a place called henrul like I said
10 out of 10. gameplay wise if you've
played any 2D Zelda you'll feel right at
home five Hearts indicate your health
you attack with a sword there's a hook
shot bombs to blow up walls and blocks
flippers which give you the ability to
swim and a feather to skip across chasms
and Hazards or Dodge attacks in terms of
Graphics I think most will agree that
the game looks absolutely gorgeous the
detailed Sprite work and the fluid
animations it's all amazing it reminds
me how much I wish Nintendo would go
back to the Minish Cap art style someday
hitting enemies just feels so satisfying
I could do this all day
I also like how the sword swings
alternate kind of like a two-head combo
as opposed to the single sword strike in
most 2D zeldas something I never touched
upon in my video is what to do if a
player happens to get stuck somehow
since we're dealing with dungeons made
by everyday people and not professional
level designers accompanied by play
testers and such the chance of
accidentally getting stuck due to an
oversight in a level design is close to
inevitable and did happen to me on more
than one occasion sure you could just
exit the level and start over but this
can be a bit demoralizing if it means
losing a ton of progress especially if
it's a big dungeon the game gets around
this problem by including a sort of
rewind mechanic it'll place you back at
the entrance of the room you're
currently in while also resetting any
progress you've made inside room
including Health pickups chests you've
opened and enemies you've defeated so
it's kind of like a safe State the only
thing I would change about it is that
currently it also restores any damage
you've taken so you can essentially use
it as a bit of a cheat and just keep
resetting the room when you're close to
dying I'd say reset everything except
the HP the mechanic should serve as a
way to avoid soft locks and not as an
easy do-over aside from that it's a
clever fix and it works honestly there's
not a whole lot more to say about the
controls or the gameplay like I said it
plays just like a Zelda game and a
competent one at that I do have a few
complaints like the absence of button
mapping or at the very least the option
to assign Quest items to a face button
of your choice I'm one of those OCD
snobs who always want certain items to
be on a specific face button you know
for muscle memory however it should be
noted that while the game has been
available on Steam since February 2022
as of yet it's still in Early Access and
constantly being worked on and updated
as such I'm also not going to dive into
stuff like performance bugs and glitches
I did encounter my fair share of
anomalies here and there like text boxes
that wouldn't go away or the Hub world
not loading properly but I think it
would be unfair to focus on these types
of issues too much and wait until the
game is you know actually finished I'd
say overall the game runs just fine it
crashed on me once but my capture
software was also acting up that day so
I'm not even sure if the game was to
blame for this that said if you you're
interested in the game yourself and want
to help test and improve the project the
studio has a dedicated Discord server
where you can report your findings and
provide feedback it Bears repeating that
this is a work in progress the same can
be said about the Hub world it's from
here that you'll be able to access to
different game modes like a tutorial
level for Dungeon building the dungeon
Builder itself and the eggs pedia where
you can play other people's creations
and right now that's about all there is
to it there's a few NPCs to talk to give
you tips and funny references but you
cannot enter most of the houses and as
mentioned before there's currently no
story mode it's clear that this is a
part of the game that's still under
construction which is to be expected
with an early access title so let's
instead jump into the main selling point
of the game which is of course the
dungeon editor and here's where it blows
my own ideas completely out of the water
in my video I opted for two separate
editors one for the dungeon map and one
for individual rooms my reasoning was
that since Zelda dungeons tend to have
some sort of transition between rooms it
would make sense to design them
separately and then assemble them in a
map editor so the engine knows where one
will room ends and the other one starts
but Super Dungeon Maker shows that it
can all be done in one editor and it's a
clever system if you create two separate
spaces close to each other the game will
treat them as One Singular room
regardless if they are connected or not
but if you space them out by a certain
amount of tiles I think four the editor
will regard them as separate and draws
an outline around each one this way when
playing the dungeon the engine knows
which areas to load or unload as well as
highlight the room you're currently in
while obscuring the rest this method
also eliminates the problem I mentioned
in my video about doorways potentially
not lining up properly when you create
them in a separate editor here you just
place a doorway in between them and
there you go problem solved as for
shaping designing and decorating the
rooms themselves it works almost exactly
the way I described it in my video so I
don't have much to add here probably the
biggest difference compared to my ideas
aside from the editor itself is the way
puzzles and object interactions are set
up in my examples I propose a system
where you link objects together by
dragging and dropping again similar to
Mario Maker while this does apply to
placing collect Collectibles inside
chests pots grass and so on when it
comes to puzzle elements like switches
spawning items or enemies or triggering
doors to open Super Dungeon makers
approach is quite different for every
self-contained space there's a total of
nine channels available kind of like the
channels on a radio assigning a channel
to an object will cause it to either
Trigger or listen for that channel
depending on what kind of object it is
so for example if you add a floor switch
and a door and set them both to channel
1 the door will open as soon as the
switch is pressed you also have access
to spawners d-spawners and area triggers
which can be used to create puzzles or
traps I'm not going to give a whole
tutorial on how it all works in fact
there's already a dedicated YouTube
channel that explains many of the basics
which I will link in the description but
needless to say you can do a lot of cool
stuff with this system now do I have any
complaints well yeah I do however
similar to the gameplay it's mostly a
matter of wanting to see more
more enemies and traps more puzzle
objects more tiles and dungeon themes
more Quest items and collectibles a
wider selection of music tracks and more
ways to customize the dungeon's look and
feel the amount on offer right now
probably isn't enough to keep most
people invested for very long and
playing other people's Creations for
more than an hour or so did make this
all the more apparent as it didn't take
long before dungeons started to feel
similar same goes for the type of puzzle
setups I was able to concoct with the
options that are available right now
however what is present is a very very
solid basis one with a lot of potential
and hard work behind it the entire game
is being developed by just two people I
mean how crazy is that the devs have
made it clear that they have all the
motivation in the world to keep
expanding the game especially now that
it's slated for a Nintendo switch
release their stretch goals include the
aforementioned story mode more playable
characters besides fink a new dungeon
theme and likely much more depending on
the game's success that's kind of the
beauty of Indie projects like these most
AAA studios are often juggling multiple
IPS and projects at the same time and
kind of reside in an ivory a tower
meanwhile Indie developers are much more
accessible and open to feedback and are
more focused on one project since they
don't have a whole Battalion of people
on the payroll thus the community can
actually be involved in shaping the
final product it's worth mentioning that
the title of this video should obviously
be taken with a grain of salt it's not
meant to be a stab at Nintendo and
there's many valid reasons why they
wouldn't want to publish a Zelda based
dungeon maker of their own be it time
restraints different priorities for the
Zelda IP a lack of inspiration or maybe
they simply don't see it as a worthy
time investment who knows like I said
before a dungeon maker type of game like
this would require continuous expansions
and updates in order to keep a player
base invested over a long period of time
because the player base is the main
driving force behind these type of games
if there's not enough people creating
new dungeons it's basically game over
and as we've seen with the latest Animal
Crossing Nintendo is already having a
hard time staying committed to
long-running projects so maybe a
Community Driven indie project is the
way to go with that said if you see the
same potential I do and want to
contribute you can either back the
project up on Kickstarter by the beta
version on Steam and or join the Discord
Community both of which you can find a
link to in the description below also
despite being Early Access there are
about 1500 dungeons made by the
community available to play right now so
there's plenty enough to keep you busy I
had a lot of fun with the game in the
past week or so and I'm interested to
see what the future holds for it I have
my gripes and wishes but I prefer to
save those for the finished product
possibly the switch version my goal was
not to dissect the game and spend 40
minutes talking about every change I'd
like to see big or small I wanted to
bring it to more people's attention
because I feel like it's a project worth
keeping an eye on and to support it if
you have the means to and that is all
for now a big thanks to Roka play for
reaching out to me and letting me try
out the game to my mods patreons and
channel members and to Morel and sjrd
and Angel drexter for joining you guys
are awesome I will see you all in the
next video this is Dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
thank you
[Music]